hi I'm Erik Bosse and this is a
breakdown of the Walking Dead Season
nine episode 15 titled the calm before
head hikes or should I say hikes spoiler
warning if you haven't seen the episode
because that pun will be both annoying
and spoilery the moment comic readers
have been dreading since the whispers
were introduced has arrived alpha
marking her border with a row of
decapitated victims in order of
importance Tara
Enid Ozzy the highwayman his buddy Alec
Tammy rows the Hilltopper DJ the
reformed savior Frankie the former negan
wife we forgot existed at E the hilltop
teen who crushed on Henry Rodney the
other hilltop teen and oh yeah Henry in
the comics Ezekiel and Rosita are in the
lineup to this TV version really hurts
if you watch this episode closely you'll
notice little details in the way the
producers adapted this dark moment to be
even more of an emotional gut punch and
little ways that they foreshadowed each
character's death starting with this
opening scene with random hobos hilda
and Myles joining the hilltop and
celebrating each anniversary anniversary
v is traditionally something wooden and
here the wooden H pendants that Hilda
cards H Ferb Hilda no no not me it's for
hilltop
home symbol of hope but H ain't just for
Hilda hilltop home hope or even Olli
correct this pendant should look
familiar because H for Henry gave Lydia
one of these Lydia wears the necklace
again this episode and she ends up
playing it at Henry's Pike and when
these red shirts are attacked skinned
and scalped by alpha as she creepily
sinks her lullaby Lydia the tattooed
lady we see one H stained with blood our
first clue that this H will end up
bloodied up two more clues are dropped
at the fair at the kingdom when the
heads of the community meet up Michonne
brings up this memory to Tara and how
people didn't trust you after seeing you
on the other side of the governor's
firing line I was gonna kill you on
sight when you washed up on our shore
and everyone was like who are you again
alright the Oceanside girl from that
season 7 episode that it won't hate it
this Tara history reminds us of her
entrance to the series in season 4 on
Team Governor briefly before fleeing the
battle and joining team Ric Plus later
Gabriel validates her step up into
leadership at the hilltop and
historically acknowledging a character's
arc is the show's Way of telling the
actor to start looking for other work in
this scene the leaders agreed to sign
Michonne's old town charter John Hancock
[Music]
Ezekiel is referencing the Massachusetts
statesman and famously signed his name
on the Declaration of Independence so
large the legend goes so King George
could read it without his spectacles
essentially John Hancock was a guy in
high school who took up a whole yearbook
page with just a big hags I compared
this document to the US Constitution
Bill of Rights but the motive for
signing this Agreement is actually
closer to a more modern international
treaty NATO with Michonne referencing
NATO's core premise here a mutual
protection pact an attack against one
community is an attack against all of us
alpha appears in disguise at this fair
wearing Hilda's dress and Sun Hat and
scalp eavesdropping on Jerry and nabila
she also overhears Earl and Tammy Rose
naming their adopted whisper baby Adam
and notice how alpha dips her hat down
because seeing that baby tells her that
these two are Hilltoppers and therefore
might know her face Ezekiel finds her
and she introduces herself as Debra from
Alexandria Debbie from Alexander which
is pretty quick considering that she
just learned Alexandria existed but
alpha does almost overplay her hand I
heard the Queen was taking care of some
official business but I look forward to
meeting her someday okay lady
and given the atrocities that Alfa
commits on Carol's adopted son I'm sure
Carol looks forward to meeting her
someday too and burning her alive
and although alpha is really pushing it
here I like how she delivers this cold
for it with a whisper and apparently
Ezekiel has zero sense of stranger
danger there's another big clue that you
might have missed but first thanks again
to Philo who sponsored this video the
hero of our returning Walking Dead
breakdowns I now use streaming services
to get all of my content no more cable I
cut off cable faster than Henry's head
from his body Philo has been perfect for
me it has over 50 channels including AMC
and Comedy Central I use it to get all
my Walking Dead fear The Walking Dead in
South Park and it's by far the easiest
way to watch The Walking Dead you can
start watching within seconds and there
is unlimited recording so you can save
as many shows as you want silos
available on Apple TV Roku Android iOS
and fire TV it's simple and affordable
only $20 a month for all this content
you can save a hundred bucks a month on
your cable bill it has been the best
solution to stay cord free and
commitment free it as a special offer to
you guys the first 50 new rock stars
fans to sign up by using our link will
get their first month for free just
visit WWF Aiello TV slash new rock stars
that's pH Aiello TV slash new rock stars
okay back to that other clue during the
fair Alden gets candy apples and this
close-up definitely feels like a visual
parallel to this apple on a stick later
on
and later eat it teases Alden I only
make fun of you like the tiniest bit for
the rest of our lives yeah big mistake
Enid never say for the rest of my life
in a world where the rest of your life
could be 20 minutes of airtime now the
movie that they screen is quack a doodle
doo with baby Huey
it's an old animated short from 1950s
Bullock Hank said that the original idea
was to show this animated short for kids
before a longer feature film for the
grown-ups in that feature it's gonna be
the 1941 classic Sullivan's Travels
now there's another foreshadowing detail
here in the animated short with baby
Huey popping off the face of the Fox and
holding it like a mask Liddy laughs but
this of course parallels the whisper
mask-making and it precedes the arrival
of her mother beside her later on Alfa
shows derald the whispers massive Walker
herd calling his community life a myth
this is taken directly from the comics
when Alfa has this moment with Rick also
the moment in which she kills her fellow
whisperer for seeing her cry is another
moment from the comics an issue 148 and
this moment actually explains alphas
entire motive because think about it if
she threatens Darrell with thousands of
walkers why does she decapitate a bunch
of random victims - seems like overkill
for alpha I think this goes deeper than
revenge for taking her daughter or even
as an act of terror this is also about
keeping her status as alpha of the
whispers like losing her daughter was a
big blow to her reputation she needed
this treachery to prove to the other
whispers that she belongs in charge and
if alpha doesn't assert herself then
there's chaos and while the victims
could have mostly been random
remember that Ozzy Alec and DJ weren't
targets originally if you look at the
original seven target six of them skewed
younger Henry Adi Rodney
Enid Tara and Frankie Tammy Rose is a
new mother so really we're talking about
the future of these communities and
vulnerable figures vulnerable enough to
be lured off by this blond stranger or
as we saw with Henry lured off by the
sound of a broken pipe where he'd be
left alone an easy target it also might
be important for Alpha to leave stronger
fighters like Daryl Ezekiel Carol and
Michonne alive so that they can better
protect her daughter now the reveal of
these pikes is haunting from their
lifeless mouths moving or the way that
their hair blows in the wind for me the
most tragic part of it was Carol's
reaction to Henry and the way Daryl runs
up and screams holding her back
it's just like the way Daryl held her
back upon her realization that Sophia
was dead but one way this dark twist
differs from the comics is the inclusion
of a witness Siddiq his eulogy tells the
alternate story of their attempt to
fight back and really this makes the
murder of all these characters a lot
more plausible and it ends their lives
on a more heroic grace note the final
shot of this episode returns to that h
pendant lets my Lydia at Henry spike and
by the way it is possible that Henry
spike could be his sharpened spear
pretty [__] up but it's so awesome a
snowflake falls on the pendant winter
has come and it's actually the first
time snow has been depicted on The
Walking Dead series this episode's title
is the calm before taken from volume 7
of The Walking Dead comic series and
part one of the expression completed by
the title of next episode the season
finale titled the storm this seasonal
shift reflects that coming storm in
which the producers promised another
left turn with a final scene that will
change everything
but for now by ending this episode with
this wooden H we are reminded of the
prologue in which we learned that the H
symbolized hope something people always
need more of which character were you
most surprised didn't end up on a pike
there were definitely some red herrings
for Ezekiel Knight say Jerry - but I'm
pretty shocked knowing from the New
Groove died like Magna or Kelly like why
even have Yumiko present Oh God they're
all dead I just met them but I am also
sad comment down below with your
thoughts follow me on Instagram and
Twitter at me a vas and subscribe to the
new rockstars channel thanks for
watching bye
[Music]